[inaudible]
on the 1st of July of this year,
very special anniversary.
We celebrated 20 years has passed since
Hong Kong stopped being part of the
United Kingdom and returns to the
People's Republic of China.
But they did this under the model one
country,
two systems.
As you know,
although China is a dictatorship,
Hong Kong was incorporated into the
country as a special administrative
region where the basic law applies.
This is a law that grants the citizens
of Hong Kong or a list of rights and
liberties,
which would be unthinkable in the rest
of China,
perhaps with the exception of Macau.
Besides this,
Hong Kong has its own currency,
its own immigration policy as well as
its own police,
customs and courts.
So in its everyday life,
the country works almost as if it were
an independent country.
Just a minute here because I did say
almost Beijing's interference has been
getting more and more intense times.
Don't think that Beijing is being
discreet about it.
Not at all.
In fact,
we already told you about it.
Heroin,
visual policy,
how pro-democracy advocates have been
tortured and killed.
As an interesting aside.
By the way,
China has recently kidnapped five
librarians in Hong Kong for spreading
ideas against China's control of the
city.
So in order to celebrate this 20th
anniversary,
Xi Jinping made his first visit to Hong
Kong.
He is the president of China thereafter
rule
[inaudible]
see Jinping in Hong Kong.
Wow.
Changing things,
visit.
Was it loaded with symbolism since it
has happened at a time when China has
been receiving lots and lots of
criticism about Hong Kong,
this visit to view at lost it for three
days and in this short period of time
the Chinese president has decided to
make things pretty clear
to,
to endanger national sovereignty and
security challenge.
The power of the central government or
use Hong Kong to carry out infiltration
and sabotage activities against the
mainland is an act that crosses the red
line and he's absolutely impermissible
cgm pain,
in other words for Beijing.
All that stuff about freedom of speech
and democracy in Hong Kong has a lot of
limits and as they are certainly not
going to allow any activist or a
politician to let things get out of
hands and challenge Beijing's control in
any
wait.
Well,
Xi Jinping doesn't just want to let them
go with a warning.
Absolutely.
Of trying to also use this visit to
presided over the largest military march
in the history of Hong Kong with Chinese
troops.
Of course,
he also used this visit to attends the
inaugural speech of Carrie Lam,
the chief executive of Hong Kong.
Aging Pink
is the Superior Authority and even the
Basic Law clearly forbids him from
meddling in local politics.
He did take the opportunity to ask the
new chief executive two things.
First,
he asked about the passing of an anti
subversion law in order to convict all
dissidence he data defend things,
assumptions,
democracy or independence for Hong Kong
and seconds.
The approval of a plan of patriotic
education for the youth.
Yep.
You heard that right?
And this is what happens in
dictatorships.
They like their kids to be educated
about their obedience.
To the regime.
So as you can probably imagine,
Hong Kong citizens,
we're not particularly willing to do
this.
And on July the first 60,000 people
demonstrated demanding more freedom and
more democracy
urge the people of Hong Kong do not give
up once we give up than we will for
certain slowly deteriorate into what is
becoming of China today.
Avery,
I'm the chairman of the League of Social
Democrats.
This is what things are like in Hong
Kong and here are visual politic.
We're going to continue to pay close
attention to the developing situation.
So do not forget to subscribe if you
haven't already.
So now that this 20th anniversary has
taken place,
there are some questions that we can't
help but ask,
how did Hong Kong do in the last 20
years?
Has It changed much then?
Well,
what is the current situation?
let's have a look at all of that.
Calm.
Is Sill Hong Kong
best news off to these 20 years?
Is that Hong Kong?
Well,
it's still simply is Hong Kong a city
completely difference compared to the
rest of China?
Let me elaborate on that.
Swamp
Hong Kong,
it's still the wealthiest and freest
city in China.
The course works and media are not under
the control of censorship and political
debates is vibrant.
Vibrant is enough of the facts of the
protests against China.
They're quite frequent.
In fact,
a demonstration for freedom with more
than 60,000 people against Tszujing
things.
Visits is a good example of this.
Furthermore,
during these years,
economic growth has been an average of
3.3% every year and well this is a
decent figure.
Now it might not be as high as in some
other Asian countries like Singapore or
some non Asian countries like Ireland,
but this is still higher than the growth
rate of most rich countries.
In fact,
during this time that more than 1
million Chinese have moved to Hong Kong
in search of it,
that's a future.
The city has also cemented his position
as a leading global financial center.
The number of publicly listed companies
on the exchange has increased three
times since 1997 and market
capitalization reached three point 2
trillion by 2016 that's equal to almost
all of Germany's GDP.
I'll stay with 60 million tourists a
year.
Hong Kong has also become quite a power
in the tourist sacks.
Oh,
hold on for just a second.
Because the country is also showing
symptoms which could indicate that the
model is getting obsolete.
[inaudible]
downfall of a single model.
It is
true that economic growth on this
island has been decent,
but it's also true that it has slowed
down with time for that savings of
collapsed in the future.
It just seems worse and not just for the
political situation.
This is probably the worst time in 20
years for Hong Kong.
John's Hong,
Choon wa former financial secretary of
Hong Kong.
There is an increasing feeling that Hong
Kong hasn't succeeded in adapting to the
modern economic environments or that
there is a risk of them being a source
of cheap tacky theme park for
businessmen and tourists.
It's like maybe it's the cities of the
pell river delta where the lack of
drawing from Hong Kong can really be
better understood.
This is the region which Hong Kong
belongs to you and traditionally the
city has been the center of attention
today.
This,
it's just not the case anymore.
I mean,
take a look at Shen Zen for example.
Yes,
Chinese city wasn't nothing but a poor
fishing town of 50,000 inhabitants 50
years ago.
Today the city is actually massive with
a population of more than 15 million
people.
It also has as many companies in the
fortune 500 as Hong Kong is an important
high tech center,
which holds many notable companies like
Penn and
and now many believe that it is Shen
Zen,
not Hong Kong,
who is destined to be the major player
in the area and also considered this
other stats.
In 1997 Hong Kong represented 20% of the
Chinese economy.
Today that figure is less than 3% this
illustrates,
well just how much things are changing.
Hong Kong's economy is stuck with
remarkably little change to show for the
past two decades.
Simon cartlidge and the truth is no.
If this has very little to do with luck
Hong Kong,
it has made a significant mistakes so
well,
the question might now be,
one of the major one.
Well these two,
there are a great place to start.
First there's the housing markets which
has the hotel design.
Awesome
real estate prices in Hong Kong have
gone through the ceiling.
The prices have gone so crazy that most
of its citizens knew that the only
chance they have of getting a house is
to get a public one and the odds of that
happening,
oh really,
really low
antonoff houses available.
All spaces become very expensive and
this makes it complicated for startups
and new companies to establish
themselves in Hong Kong.
This triggers crazy situations like this
one Hong Kong parking space sells for
record $664,300 and the problem here is
not a lack of lands,
not at all.
In fact less than 25% of Hong Kong
surface area is urbanized and there are
other possibilities like using the seat
plans.
It's really not the issue.
The Hong Kong,
it has a very free economy but freest in
the world according to the index of
economic freedom.
But it is not free when it comes to land
housing and town planning in Hong Kong.
The governments is the one in charge of
the housing sector and it has become a
complete failure in the last few
decades.
There are over 200 hectares of land
available for building in the urban
areas.
The shortage of housing is real,
but that is because of deliberate
manipulation of the market by the
government.
John White,
a barrister and chairman of Friends of
cycle pay close attention yet because
housing developments have been frozen
because of law from the colonial times
for decades,
the local government least farmer's land
in order to grow rice.
These communities support the government
in Beijing and nobody wants to mess with
them.
It really is a totally crazy system and
some people are suspicious band.
They have good reasons to be.
The government may have tried to go on a
fever from some oligarchs with big real
estate deals.
Some convictions have actually shown
this corruption and of confirms the
suspicious links between government
workers and the real estate magnets of
Hong Kong.
This might explain why seven of the 14
richest real estate investors off from
home
calm.
This leads us on to another issue and
that's the growing amount of crony
capitalism.
Okay.
Uncertain people agree capitalism has
lost its strength in the last years to a
system with a similar name but a totally
different essence and that system is
crony capitalism.
Under the British,
the government was pro business but not
of business.
Since 1997 business interests have been
baked into the political system.
Conflicts of interest of multiplied
cronyism has grown,
okay
in many sectors,
competition has been replaced by well
connected oligopolies and monopolies and
the worst thing is that things are
getting worse.
It was trying to raise regaining its
power in the city as an example of the
liaison office,
which is like the Chinese delegation,
that is even giving out loans with
better conditions to friendly companies
in order to increase their influence and
their political power and what to know
what's required in order to get one of
these loans well you need to have
connections and some make all of this
worse.
This is all surrounded by the political
conflict that we've already told you
about.
Anyway,
it is carry lambs and mission to address
all these problems.
Her legitimacy is also questionable.
After all,
she wasn't elected by the citizens.
She was elected by a group of people who
are led by Beijing's directive.
It's fine.
There was this time of year when Hong
Kong was thought to be the city on the
hill for China's political change.
Unfortunately,
they things look quite different
nowadays and the question becomes,
what will the future of Hong Kong be
like?
Will it be in the light?
What would it be in the shadows?
Well,
now it's your turn.
We'd love to know what you think.
Please do leave us a comment below this
video as well as in this survey,
and if you did like this video,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
twice a week.
Also,
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but one not mine,
and there's a ways,
thank you for watching.